the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
welcome to the into the impossible
podcast a production of UC San Diego's
Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination and it's a real treat to
have one of my heroes my heroines
however you want to say it uh in physics
and not only a physicist we have a lot
of physicists on the show but an
experimental physicist and you may be
one of the first if not the first honest
to goodness experimentalist who has come
on this program so thank you Elena it's
a real treat to have you here
such nice words yes that make me happy
I'm glad you make a lot of people happy
think about me as a woman and an
experimentalist yes I'd like to do
things with my own hands yes absolutely
and it's wonderful to have you here I
want to give a brief introduction for
the few people out there who may not
know you uh you were born next week in
the time uh that I won't mention but uh
your birthday is March 12th which is a
which is only two days before Einstein's
birthday so that's wonderful and
unfortunately Stephen Hawking's date of
being deceased was March 14th I believe
and she is an Italian-American particle
physicist she's been a professor at
Columbia University since 1986. she's
the founder and spokesperson of the
Xenon Dark Matter experiment which is a
major component of our conversation
today uh she's known for her work with
noble gas uh Noble liquid detectors and
our contributions to particle
astrophysics in the particular search
for dark matter which was the subject of
your visit or your talk that you gave to
the public as part of the Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination we
we screened a film that you're in so
you're not only a wonderfully
accomplished physicist a professor at a
top ivy league university but you're
also a movie star and uh I think you
know I mentioned to you earlier my wife
thought I was interviewing Sophia Lauren
I just saw the film last night but um I
do want to just mention just a brief
background you were a student in the
University of Naples
we were at Harvard
um in the 80s working as a postdoctoral
researcher for Carlo Rubio's group uh
who's a well-known Noble Laureate and
the subject of a book called Nobel
dreams and I'm not sure if you make a
cameo in that book you may you may not I
forgot when I'm I'm I'm crying liquid
argon tears it's true
uh so she's had so many awards uh but
I'll focus on one of them she's NSF
career award she received a medal
official de la republika Italian from
the Italian president Carlo
Champion
uh she has an asteroid named after her
so that is a type of dark matter which
is named after you it's asteroid uh 26
86 86 Elena April no way yeah discovered
by Italian uh amateur astronomer silvano
casully in 2006. do you know that I know
it
check Wikipedia folks of course uh she
received the Lancelot and Berkeley New
York Community Trust prize for
meritorious work in astronomy from the
American Astronomical Society and she is
gracing us this quarter at UC San Diego
as one of our Margaret Burbidge visiting
professors so welcome again I want to
talk about right now I want to talk
about Margaret Burbage because uh the
visiting professorship that you hold
currently in honor is named in honor of
my colleague Margaret Burbidge who is a
hundred years young and she lives up in
the Bay area of California but she is
one of the founding members of the
center for astrophysics and space
Sciences where we found ourselves today
and among many of her distinctions
ranging from uh the uh not the Royal
astronomer there's some controversy
about that but she was the astronomer uh
who led the Greenwich Observatory she
was President I believe of the American
Astronomical Society many many things
she was one of the leaders and founders
of this Center that we're in now but she
also um among her many honors she uh
trained in some sense and befriended a
young astronomer by the name of Vera
Rubin and of course beer Rubin is well
known as being credited with finding
some of the most convincing evidence for
the existence of dark matter so I wanted
to just uh highlight that fact that UCSD
has this deep connection through
Margaret Burbidge and Jeff Burbage her
husband the two of them were very close
with Vera Rubin and her husband and when
she did a sabbatical here in the 60s
that's when she learned a lot about the
type of spectroscopic studies that she
could later use to measure rotation
curves of these distant galaxies and
really provide uh some convincing
evidence for the existence of dark dark
dark matter so I want to ask you first
what is it about dark matter why does it
uh transfix the imagination is it the
name is it this mysterious properties
that it has of seeming in
non-interactivity because I know a lot
of people who don't like to interact are
very introverted but Dark Matter seems
to be quite introverted in a sense what
fascinates people and maybe I'll ask you
what what interests you the most about
dark matter
I think simply is because if you think
that we we I mean the stuff that we know
makes such a little amount in this
universe is just how can you not think
about finding out what the rest is so I
don't know if the name is correct this
dark matter I mean we narrowed it from
sweetheart
but um yeah what is it about it I think
we have to do it I mean there is no
other way I mean it's so important
because
when you tell your children or your
friends I mean what are you doing you're
studying dark matter and
and the way I usually present it is that
we're trying to find out what the 95
percent
of the universe is made of and they say
what do you mean what the 95 of the
universe is made of because I mean for
normal people this is an intriguing
question but for us it's much more
intriguing because
the connection about dark matter and
what it is and particle physics and what
we learned all this life about the
building blocks of Nature and
the fundamental laws of physics and all
that can change once we find out what
this dark matter is so
it's the connection for me is the
connection with astrophysics astronomy
cosmology particle physics which
actually is the most appealing I I
cannot think of another topic today
which unifies all these disciplines
right and I guess you know some of the
question uh that naturally comes up is
is dark matter a new type of material is
it actually matter or could it somehow
be you know a placeholder for some
ignorance that we might have about how
gravity Works can you say something
about whether or not this is still a
deep controversy within your field
I don't I wouldn't say it's a deep
controversy but we have had mon modified
gravity theories and
we have more recently heard about this a
new theory of gravity from our friend
Eric ferlinda so it's not a controversy
but there are people out there who might
and I don't know if they're correct we
don't know
uh it's it's plausible but any new
Theory would have to explain all the
phenomena that we
see and observe and as far as I know to
date none of this theory that some of
these people have put forward are able
to explain fully
the observations that we have at all
scales so until then
uh I'm just keep looking the the sort of
a thorny issue that I've thought about a
lot which is how do you know when to
stop doing an experiment when we teach
our undergraduates there's a known
answer that they're trying to get and
they stop when they get something that's
reasonably close to that answer or you
know could conceivably convince their
their ta that they're on the right track
but before we get to how do you turn off
an experiment which I think is an
interesting question in the context of
um of Pursuits where there may not be an
answer we may never detect gravitational
wave B modes in the CMB for example
maybe it will be impossible to detect
dark matter who knows but we'll talk
about that in a minute but before that I
want to talk about how do you decide to
start an experiment what gave you the uh
as as we say the gumption the gall if
you will to start this incredibly
ambitious uh many tens of millions of
dollars experiment that you've raised
with your collaborators and and what
gives you the notion that it's time to
pursue something and start off on
something that could be a 20 30 40 year
Quest
well that's easy to answer because when
I started which is more than 15 years
ago the field was so way back different
than that the situation was quite
easiness sense because we have had we
had had few detectives few Technologies
very very powerful but
small scale detectors and
they were searching specifically for
this hypothetical candidate for that
matter which we call the weekly
interacting massive particle so designed
specifically for that to measure the
tiny energy that would be released in a
material
if this hypothetical particle would
care to scatter off an atom of that
material and so we were talking about
this beautiful cryogenic barometers at
that time
and they had to explore the little
region of this so-called parameter space
namely the interaction strength of a
wimp with a nucleon
and at that time this technology is the
scaling up of those technology was
already cleared then that was very
painful costly and technically
technologically very challenging
so I happen to attend a meeting at the
Snowmass meeting in Colorado I think it
was and I listened to a lot of this dark
matter talks and so the picture of the
status of of the art at that time and I
connected
quickly to the development that I was
doing for NASA for gamery astrophysics
I've been developing this liquid Xenon
detectors for detecting the radiation
the nuclear synthesis from Supernova
from Nova and so I decided I thought
that it's my my detector would be
actually better
and more scalable than this
technology of the time and that's how I
got the idea of proposing the Xenon
experiment
so and if I'm not mistaken you have a
patent related to that gamma-ray
astronomical yeah that was with one of
my graduate students
there's a light detecting device we did
a lot of work in the lab with this Noble
liquefied gases and so then I settled
onto liquidzine
and a lot of the work was done for as I
said as a Content telescope to use it
when it come to a telescope for Imaging
gamma rays from let's say nuclear
synthesis in stars and what is Xenon how
does it compare to say helium which you
can go down to the supermarket and buy a
balloon full of what is the casino and
you like helium I know YouTube but we
have had our time to
to detect electrons in helium or to
actually see scintillation from it so
the advantage of Xeno and all these rare
gases is that it is the most amazing in
terms of when you cool it down when you
liquefied in terms of ionizer and
scintillator so it gives you the highest
yield the largest number of photons per
unit energy of free electron per unit
energy that gives you signals that you
want to have available to detect
some radiation so it's a great radiation
detection medium
it is in addition
um very easy I mean with time after 15
years now we learned how to make it
clean to remove electronegative
impurities
stuff oxygen-like which eat
easily electrons and if you lose the
signal you know
we're talking about a handful of
electron when we talk about detecting
the energy of a document a particle
interaction so even few electrons losses
detrimental so we need to keep this
material clean we learned how to do it
the other Advantage compared to let's
say argon or helium is that when you
liquefy the temperature is relatively
warm so as I say sometimes easy
cryogenics
compare let's say to what you're used to
right so we have invented cryo coolers
pulse tube refrigerators which can keep
this Gene and in my lab we used to be in
small detector size we used to use
nitrogen and alcohol and make a molasses
I will steer with the mountains so it's
hard to keep a detective for years and
years if you want to steer the thing so
mechanical coolers have come very handy
and we have made a lot of progress on
that for that specific liquid
temperature let's say minus 100 degree
or so C because most of the cryo coolers
you find on the market are optimized for
liquid nitrogen typically right so for
liquisine and we had to develop with a
company in Japan a specific called a
path to refrigerator so it's very good
ionizer scintillator
uh you can keep it clean you and then
for dark matter or research is another
of great advantage or requirement that
you have is that there are no intrinsic
ready activities because you're
searching for a very rare event if you
have the example is the Argon liquid
argon is also a very good candidate for
dark matter as Target and detector
medium but you have the big problem of
the Argon 39
intrinsic radioactivity which gives you
a backerail of rate and so of course we
have solved that as well today because
we are trying to extract this argon from
Wells and remove this intrinsic red
activity in Xenon you don't have
intrinsic radioactivities other than
maybe the Krypton traces of Krypton and
we have learned again with time how to
distill
yes cryogenic distillation is being used
a lot we have huge distillation column
on the Xenon setup to remove the Krypton
let's say yeah because Krypton has this
tiny amount of Krypton 85 which is
radioactive radioactive as well so all
these things make it and also I think
coming back to helium you have to see
also where most of the work went you
know because still today in my lab in
many other labs we're learning about the
fundamental physics the microphysics
sometimes we say oh this liquid we still
have a lot of things we don't understand
the recombination process because the
mechanisms through which this light and
charges are produced in its materials
are quite complex there are interplay
between applying an electric field to
keep the free electrons separate from
the parent iron stuff which eats the
scintillation and the
assignments which are forms and go to
ground state giving you light can be
formed also through the recombination
process so it's a very complicated
physics and also physics that we had to
learn to find out a very low energies
right because the work I did with nas
within the NASA framework thing was
Mammy the energies the famous 511 kV
line and now you're asking what is the
energy that a nuclear recall from a wimp
interaction gives you and this is few KV
and so the first question I had when we
started Xenon was how many electrons do
you expect from a KV of a nuclear recoil
right which I didn't know because I was
dealing with gamma rays alphabetical
what is a nuclear record right so we
started to make experiments with
neutrons in the lab to produce Neutron a
nuclear recoil from Neutron scattering
on Xenon and measuring the yield how
many charges how many photons you find
in these detectors
in order essential question to calibrate
yeah so and we still haven't finished
this Quest because of course we want to
go lower and lower in energy right more
resolution and so forth but as an
example I bring always my proposal the
Zen proposal at the threshold I don't
remember 10 or 20 KV as an energy
threshold when we first did the first
prototype even xenon-10 we could show
that the energy threshold was much was
much lower than that and the reason is
that we had no idea that we could go so
low I mean nobody knew really how low in
threshold but now you know these
detectors can be a single Photon
sensitive single electron sensitivity so
that's something you learn with time so
the current limits that that you have
um have achieved with Xenon
um are really the the most competitive
in the world I would say although we
should say and maybe I'm curious because
I can't resist I have an expert and an
Italian expert no less um what do you
think about this Dharma excess that's
been going on since I was a graduate
student that seems to say that suggests
that there is not only a Dark Matter
existing particle but it it behaves
exactly as you'd expect from the sort of
distribution of Dark Matter particles in
our galaxy and the relative increase or
decrease is sort of a wind and running
into the wind and out of the wind as the
Earth orbits around the Sun each year uh
and and getting the so-called annual
modulation so this is a many many Sigma
I forget how many It Is by now but a
claim is that it's 12 or more yeah we
haven't talked a few weeks ago again at
this conference
expert yeah so tell me what do you yeah
when I was a grad student it was five
Sigma they have increased the
significance of this modulation they
clearly see a beautiful signal which
modulates with the right phase
and it's just it just remains as of
today unclear what the hell is doing
that because if that were coming from
the vanilla wimp hypothesis the same
whims that we're looking for in these
detectives and many others based on that
rate and that amplitude we would have to
see a huge signal which we haven't seen
and so the only way to answer that
question modulation is indeed the most
direct and beautiful way of discovering
a wind and so for that we have actually
made a search with our own xenundated
Xeno 100 data to search for any
modulation and test for leptophilic
models and whatever we still don't find
anything so the question is why is it so
special sodium iodide which is the
Target that this experiment uses
after so many years since I started
myself we have finally come to the point
where we have other experiments using
that same technology testing the Dharma
signal unfortunately these experiments
as of today they haven't reached the
sensitivity of the statistics good
enough to say yes or no so they keep
taking data and I'm waiting we don't
find these signals in Xenon we don't
find it in other detectors so it remains
a mystery
and so we don't go there they insist but
if I were the Dharma people I would have
taken my detector and moved it somewhere
else I'll give it to somebody else to
take some data and analyze the data my
understanding is there a little bit
they're very stubborn on keeping them
yeah
so is it natural not to be stubborn one
of the things that that um that was so
resonant with me uh in the film chasing
Einstein which is your um one of your
debut it's probably your debut in the on
the big screen and a wonderful
documentary which is available for
people to purchase online iTunes YouTube
Etc
um and they cut to you and they show you
along with some I guess you're listening
to Shakira in the background very
elegant very uh and they and they show
you and then they show you going into
the lab and you're in the lab you're
with your students you're clearly at
home
foreign
[Music]
the wiring was you I was screaming at
the other girl the other student
but you left it around
and you say a lovely thing uh you know
again resonated with me very strongly
and you say this is my baby this is my
baby
this is my baby
and I love it every time I come in here
my students
you know sometimes I shout I scream and
shout really I hate to see those
cable ties left hanging and I'm sure you
find some
if your cable tie is hanging it means in
your house you also and who is going to
want to have a guy like you so I keep
telling them
you have a better chance to find a woman
Xeno Anton has been operating for more
than one and a half year now so we're
very close to open that box and and see
what what nature is for us
you want to be confident and excited and
hopeful that maybe this time is the time
and you will see a sign of dark matter
it's it spoke to me in that this sort of
personification or anthropomorphizing
your experiment uh which is which is
something you know we all bleed cry and
sweat on our experiments and I don't
think the average you know layperson
appreciates just how hard it is to do
these results especially given the fact
that we seem to come up you know at
least from some perspectives of null
detections of no no positive results we
have not yet detected as I said
convincing evidence for you know
inflationary origin of the universe if
you will we may never
um and it may be it may be that
inflation did take place but we don't
have the sensitivity and never will or
it could be that inflation didn't take
place and there might be some other
Alternatives how do you continue to
persist in the in the face of this so
the dhamma folks clearly feel they have
um something to prove to the community
and that they are not being accepted at
face value I don't know of any other
field where such a large statistical
significance would be dismissed but
let's
yeah so where where do where do you get
your yeah when do we get as
experimentalists when do we realize it's
time to wrap up when I started the field
with a certain stage and they made a lot
of sense to jump in and in fact the
major achievement that I feel I've made
with my collaboration and experiment is
really to explore not one not two but
four or five orders of magnitude from
where we were then in terms of testing
the interaction strength or whims with
matter you know excluding cross-sections
which are lower lower and lower four
five words magnitude in about 10 years
12 years is a major deal in this in this
and any other fields huge swaths and now
we're getting to the point where we are
making these detectors more and more
sensitive larger and larger there were
the scalability vision that one had
everybody knew but I mean you have this
Noble liquid you can make them larger
we're talking about not few hundred a
few tenths of a kilogram we're talking
now about 80 thousand kilogram ten
thousand kilogram of Target which has
never been done and with that kind of
Step now we want to seize the last
little bit of this so-called theoretical
prediction
we are basing our detector the detectors
have been designed specifically
for a particle candidate which is called
the whim so all these detectors have
been designed specifically to search for
mostly massive winds search has been
done mostly for tens of GV hundreds of
GV up to the TV scale massive wins for
which this target specifically Xenon is
very very good because it has a lot of
nucleons the Xenon atom is very large
and if a Wim scatters of a nucleus he
likes to scatter with all the nucleus
nucleons coherently so the larger the
the nucleus you have the better you're
off
in the spin independent so-called way
so now we reach the point where we're
going to exclude maybe just one order of
many we we are separated from a level of
background that we can't avoid despite
all our smart which is the neutrinos and
so neutrinos from the Sun from the
atmospheric neutrino the Supernova
Neutron are going to give us a signal
soon but we have that last one order
magnitude maybe towards the menu to
separating us from the signal of
neutrinos
and so I think at that point you have to
stop in the sense that you turn your
detector into a beautiful neutrino
detector but there are many others so
the the natural stopping time is coming
to the to the time when the neutrino
signal is going really to
make it impossible for you to find
a signal from wimp if it is so at the
level of neutrino so
but we still have a way to go because
with the current generation of
experiment which is about to start the
Xenon and tone we're going to go still
and order a magnitude above the neutrino
floor almost and then if we're still
finding nothing that is a little bit
more and a lot of pain to get there
because it's amazing how you scale them
up but you gain very very little yeah
exponentially small and then a certain
point you have to stop because I mean
you can't even distinguish these
particles if they exist from the
more known aspected particles such as
neutrinos so we do know when we will
stop I will stop then yeah maybe
the movie I'm still hopeful that in the
next round which still is going to last
four or five years from now of search
searching for about another four or five
years so this decade for me is going to
be critical because we are going to
start to search
competing after the experiment with the
same technology starting and we are
competing to start
at the same time we might have we will
have a liquid organ as well experiment
starting this decade the LHC is starting
again after this shutdown
we have indirect detection with this
beautiful telescopes from Ice Cube to
the firm is still out there and we have
EMS out there so again we said that last
decade actually yeah exactly I know we
keep saying the same thing but but we
are going more and more down right so in
terms of theoretical framework I mean of
course our friends theorists are so
smart they'll keep coming up with
alternative and you know very well
already the absence of a signal in all
these channels from direct detection
indirect direct has prompted a wealth of
searches in other enabling energy
regions so low must swim searches with
accelerator with beautiful little
Technologies because the cross sections
shoots up at low mass so you don't need
such large detectors and we have a lot
of effort going on at low mass
and
So eventually this decade again at least
from the direct detection which is the
most in my opinion direct way of finding
this particle in the from the hail of
this galaxy
should be concluded because if we still
don't find in this decade there will be
very little separating us from the
neutrino okay well in March of 2030 you
and I are going to be back here and I'm
going to talk about how beautiful the
neutrinos is
so uh so I mentioned that I have a
favorite quote uh comes from Oscar Wilde
a quotes uh in a book
all right his writing lady windmere's
fan uh he has a character Lord
Darlington quip
the definition of a cynic is a man who
knows the price of everything but the
value of nothing and I think uh it's
sometimes hard to convince people you
know when they ask me what I'm looking
for and I say mostly nothing or static
or or whatever noise noise yeah we spend
all our days looking at noise and trying
to get rid of an understanding trying to
understand it and model it Etc
that's one of the popular misconceptions
of scientists first of all they think we
all have beards and we are rubbing our
beards and uh and that's obviously not
true in in either one of our cases but I
think there is this sort of impression
that um you know it's only science if
you make a discovery you know there's
sort of positivist you you have to
actually have something clear rather
than ruling things out in the film uh
there's a young a physicist postdoc who
says you know every paper should be
celebrated like a Triumph like a victory
it was a great it was a great quote yeah
and I think there is some value in that
um I think there is this tendency to
look at people like Einstein you know
who is the film uh namesake character in
chasing Einstein and you know kind of
hauled him up this level of authority
and sort of almost like a halo effect
that no nothing that he did could could
possibly have failed and been wrong and
in fact as we know he made many many
blunders and some say he made more
blunders than none than than actual
successes I don't know if I agree with
that I think he because I always say he
could have had a good career if he
didn't uh but but you know a lot of what
comes up in physics is is serendipitous
and we don't expect it uh the discovery
of the cosmic microwave background the
CMB that I studied was completely
serendipitous that's a beautiful one the
discovery of the of the acceleration of
the universe of dark energy that was
also serendipitous they were looking for
exactly the opposite and I wonder you
know if by focusing maybe this is just
too philosophical to get into but uh
discoveries of you know your your
countrymen Galileo Galilei he he
discovered things completely by accident
and then applied scientific you know
principles in the scientific method
towards sussing out all the details of
that new field that he and basically
landedly invented by virtue of this
Exquisite technology that he pioneered I
see similarities with you you Pioneer
this tool you've vacuumed up all of this
parameter space and that's sort of a
natural thing to do
um but I worry you know I wonder
sometimes if uh what's driving us
Galileo never really released the plans
for his telescope so that even his
friend Kepler could reproduce it because
he wanted to keep making these
low-hanging fruit discoveries and solve
and I wonder you know is that driven by
this competition as you know my my book
I focus a lot on competition and whether
or not what role the Nobel Prize plays
in fact in the film you open in your
office I guess I haven't been there yet
I hope to someday visit you in your
office but but with a poster of Marie
Curie and you talk the first thing that
comes out is about the Nobel Prize and
how she won two and I wonder uh is that
a motivation for you I know your your
advisor won a Nobel Prize and and
obviously it's it's a it's a it's a very
um dominant theme overarching both of
our fields
um does it play does it play a role in
you uh personally is it something that
influences you personally I have to say
no to be honest we are embedded in this
idea that of course that's the highest
honor you can get and it would be
absolutely great it's true but he never
played a role I have to say because
actually I see that when people get The
Nobel Prize directly I had two good
friends from Rubio to George Harper I
was very close to these two great
scientists but they changed completely
they get completely
paranoic and crazy yeah right so I don't
like it I think yes Elliot so the Nobel
Prize a ticket to your funeral because
you never do anything good after you win
no so I I don't look forward to that but
of course the statement I made about
Madame Curie was very natural because
well she's known or she is the first
woman and the one who got it twice so at
such different times and I wonder I
don't know how she behaves after
probably she was still normal yeah I am
more proud about seeing Madame Curie
more in reading some other biographies
about the real woman yeah because we
tend to forget that the scientists like
you and me have a life yeah let's talk
about that in particular you know both
of us are parents of daughters and uh
and and I know uh that you know that in
addition to uh to Margaret Burbidge and
Vera Ruben spending some time here uh
Maria Gephart Mayer was here and when
she won the Nobel Prize her son told me
that the newspaper said La Jolla
housewife wins Nobel Prize and you see
and I wonder you know what is your how
do you think of yourself are you a
scientist are you a mother how do you
picture yourself as a human being what
what what what defines you to you I am
what I am I am a woman and I happen to
like to be in the lab and to build great
technology instruments and I am most
proud of my daughters because that I
used to say and I wrote it down they are
the best experiments I made
a successful experiment I ever made and
I would never do anything differently of
course you still feel guilty about the
time you took away from them because the
lab doesn't have time I mean parties the
birthday missing
but they they knew when they grew up
Stronger by knowing that his mother has
always something on her mind she's
thinking while she's cooking yeah but to
me that's and I want to instill in every
young woman and student today
approaching signs that they can do the
science
they have to do the science but without
forgetting that they're women and caring
to find a guy or whoever they want them
be happy in their the rest of their
uh
Persona make babies because I mean I
think that every woman should have that
experience I mean and I always felt that
I actually would how do I feel I always
felt
stronger than my colleagues I was the
first woman in the physics department in
Colombia that's right so a lot you can
imagine I've been always alone in these
meetings very very much alone so I'm
vaccinated I never care though right
because when I then got pregnant of
Julia at Columbia
uh I mean the proof the people who had
problems were more my colleagues than
myself because they were not used to see
right
and the bias is is large I mean what are
you doing here you should be home
resting and I say no but I'm fine I'm
not feeling so weird I'm feeling good
you're not that kind of doctor I mean I
I have no idea but you know you have to
keep going and these young women today
have to know that women like the Vera
Rubin and I'm sure Margaret
I mean women can have a life and be a
great scientist yeah it doesn't have to
exclude one doesn't have to exclude the
other yeah I think it would be a Pity in
fact what I find most
sometimes sad is to see colleagues smart
women
who actually made the choice of made
renounces and didn't decide at the right
time to fulfill other dreams in their
life and then eventually you can they
regret and then it's too late and so I
think we should encourage yeah it's I
always say it's the hardest possible
thing you could do and I I'm speaking as
from male perspective but you know I
know it's a lot harder but but being a
parent is you know it is an experiment
and and you hope that they don't they're
not null experiments and they yield good
results I have to say that I am you know
you would enjoy coming over and helping
with my twin one-year-olds because they
produce a lot of Dark Matter diapers so
you'd have first-hand experience direct
experience
um so there are a lot of uh uh of ways
we could we could go with from here but
I do want to just maybe close out the
discussion with one of the ways that you
inspire physicists like me is as a
leader and it's something interesting
that kind of relates back to Einstein so
you know Einstein was asked to be the
first president of the new nation of
Israel and he was like why should I do
that they're like because you're smart
yeah but but really there's a halo
effect where people think you know if
someone can do one thing that it
translates immediately over into some
other discipline which it doesn't but
you've managed to do two things that are
totally different right to excel in your
branch of physics and to also be a
scientific manager and a leader and
there's there's I think it's it's almost
harder to do that as I say you know as I
said earlier it's not like herding cats
at least cats basically stay on a plane
or Surface but you know butterflies are
hurting neutrinos or dark matter wimps
um how do you how did you do that how do
you do that what are any tricks you know
we didn't I didn't learn any management
skills no and I think some people have
it better than others I mean I thank my
mother for that is that intuition that
we have in understanding people I'm
breathing people right I don't take very
long to figure out when to talk to you
in certain ways
and so I managed to keep together this
collaboration which Grew From 20 people
to almost 200 people
and I'm still managing that but the way
I do it is still my own way sometime I
go a bit off the tangent but typically I
use my
so-called intuition this this connection
that I have with people I can read very
easily and I motivating that I
definitely I motivated my students are
my babies I mean I care a lot about
every member of this collaboration yeah
and you see you see a lot of your
colleagues usually treating their
students like someone who can you can
see only once a week maybe once even a
month for me not much just kidding
myself
and for me it's everyday life I see it
and I want to know everything what they
do I'm So Into it's true I always am
curious but the reason why I'm curious
how are you doing how is it going with
your wife how is your kid to my person
it's because I know first of all it's
it's probably selfish yeah because
somebody happy works better yeah so when
I when I sense that something is wrong
which is a personal matter I try to help
them solve it because I know that they
otherwise there's an impasse it's also a
bit selfish but I do care about
what they're doing with their life as
well and try to help them yeah and try
to help them also become not just great
scientists but also great human beings
and if that means also learning how to
make a good espresso yes and how to cut
cable ties so that the woman will not
think of them as sloppy all right I mean
that goes without saying that's for me
it's important too and we will have
workshops on how to make the best
lasagna oh that well I will I mean even
that I would I'd like to be a good
physicist and hope to get a great woman
if you don't even not to cook a good
meal for her
very very true
um so my final question is the question
I ask everyone from Nobel laureates
Pulitzer Prize winners uh entrepreneurs
Etc have been so gracious with their
time as you have with yours to come on
this podcast and that is
um we focus here at the Arthur C Clarke
Center for human imagination on this
question of imagination which is
naturally connected to creativity the
unique human capacity for reason I think
is is what sets us apart what
distinguishes us but the question of you
know can't pedagogically can you can you
teach someone to be the next Illinois I
mean can you teach somebody to do the
kinds of things the skill set the meta
skills that we need to be the successes
in our field is that a teachable skill
or is it you have to be born with it
obviously lasagna you can teach but you
know some like you know Cuisine I
wouldn't recommend on anybody even if
you were my teacher so is it something
in as a physicist can you teach someone
to be a physicist a lot of theoretical
physicists say you know I've interviewed
have said well we tend to think of
everyone in theoretical as Einstein and
so I can't be like Einstein so I won't
even try but but we're experimentalists
we're dealing with the real hardcore
substantive life and and actually
contact with nature not only and I'm not
disparaging theorists there might some
of them are my best friends but but can
you teach creativity can you teach
imagination that allows you to be
successful in our field of experimental
astrophysics no no Brian you cannot
teach someone to be creative to be
imaginative
that's really something that you have
but you can help a lot
whatever is the little bit that you have
in someone Channel it in the right
direction but I have seen over and over
with my student my postdoc
you can make them better but if they
didn't have to begin with the Curiosity
the creativity they're never going to
invent something in the lab they're
going to be more follower than leader in
that sense but not leader in terms of
taking initiative and making something
new out of nothing I at least my
experience has been so far that is hard
to teach that's not a skill yeah so you
can teach them to be great
experimentalist I have turned the best
theoretical physics student into good
experimentalists but usually I don't get
from them that innovative
thing that you get from someone who is
really as I say and
a lab animal
I have had a few lab animals in my life
I want and I'm not as good as some of
them but you really see that that is
something that these people just have it
yeah they just get better and better at
it but you can't beat that you can't
teach it has to be something but maybe
I'm wrong no definitely
well no no it's been such a pleasure
having you on the Arthur C Clarke Center
for human imaginations into the
impossible podcast I want to encourage
folks to subscribe and like and review
and rate on iTunes and elsewhere
wherever you get your podcast wherever
you watch online on YouTube and
elsewhere
um Ellen anything you want to promote
you're going to be giving a colloquium
here in at UC San Diego in April I
believe and we can't wait to see that we
just had our public event you're around
as uh the rest of this quarter uh as the
visiting Margaret Burbage Professor
anything you want to um talk about that
we didn't get a chance to cover on on
today's podcast I just wish here like I
do a bitter Colombia but
foreign legs to encourage every student
I've been meeting with the undergraduate
of women in physics I will meet with the
graduate students in physics women in
physics but every young man and woman
was in love with physics through
come and see me on campus while I'm here
yeah or talk to me because I think the
future of course in like in everything
else is in this a young minds and we
ought to give them whatever we have
learned because as I grow older you
realize you have a lot to tell to to
share with the younger people of course
but if you don't have a chance to talk
you will never be able to pass the
message
so I'm here so they should come and see
we're very honored and uh grateful for
you spending your time here but thank
you it's been a pleasure to be here to
find more discoveries uh together thank
you thank you hi the only thing we can
be short of about the future is that it
will be absolutely fantastic
[Music]
thank you